today on the matt walsh show democrat
politicians and hundreds of others
gathered yesterday to mourn dante wright
the violent criminal
shot by police last week during the
funeral service he was literally
elevated to the status of a guardian
angel we'll talk about the whole
grotesque display today also five
headlines including a new angle on the
uh mikaya bryant shooting that
absolutely confirms that it was
justified shooting something we already
knew from the body cam but this
reinforces it and a mother speaks out
about masking policies at a school board
meeting it was a real truth to power
moment and uh it's worth listening to
we'll play that also environmental
activists pollute in the name of saving
the planet and aoc says that racism is
causing climate change we'll get into
all that and more today on the matt
welsh show
[Music]
[Applause]
well there was no golden casket this
time but it was a scene otherwise
reminiscent of george floyd's funeral
and summary canonization last year
yesterday dante wright who was shot by
police after resisting arrest was
laid to rest in minneapolis hundreds of
mourners came from all over the nation
prominent politicians public figures
other luminaries gathered to pay their
respects the funeral was nationally
televised
on multiple
uh
cable news channels the governor of
minnesota who also attended issued a
proclamation calling for a statewide
moment of silence in memory of the great
dante wright saint dante wright the
blessed dante wright the statement from
governor tim walls said quote
dante wright was beloved by his family
neighbors and community and had his
entire young life ahead of him we mourn
the loss of dante wright and as a state
we offer our deepest condolences to the
right family we know this tragedy is
connected to the deep systemic racism in
our society that black people in
minnesota and across the country face
every single day while nothing can bring
dante wright back to his loved ones we
must continue to work to enact real
meaningful change at the local state
national levels to fight systemic racism
so that every person in minnesota black
indigenous brown or white can be safe
and thrive we must be steadfast in our
accountability for
to change from the top to the bottom and
not rest until we create a different
future for dante wright's son and every
other child like him
that was the governor of minnesota
moment of silence across the whole state
for dante right
i i uh
assume that people die in minnesota
probably every day
almost none of them get the statewide
moan of silence dante wright did
now of course as we know wright's death
had nothing to do with racism whatsoever
it didn't even have a plausible
theoretical connection to racism
whatever else you might say about the
manner of his demise you cannot say that
he was killed for his race well you can
say that if you're a shameless
exploitative opportunistic lying hack
like governor tim walls
and speaking of shameless exploitative
opportunistic lying hacks al sharpton
was unsurprisingly in attendance
sharpton has in recent years found his
calling in delivering eulogies for
violent criminals he didn't know
and no one knew until they died on
camera during an arrest
the challenge for sharpton and most of
the other people who spoke at the
service is that
you know usually in a eulogy you pay
tribute to the many wonderful traits and
good deeds of the deceased
now dante wright didn't have many of
those frankly it seems so instead
sharpton gave a rather lazy stump speech
about racism where he employed a
metaphor that was both absurd and
dishonest let's listen
the generation before me
they
boycotted in montgomery
against the segregation laws in alabama
and they
boycotted the bus company
1955
they started december 1st
and for a solid year
they wouldn't ride the bus
they said it was better to walk in
dignity
than to ride in shame
and they brought the facts of alan
batman's segregation
but dr king and doctor haven't that did
rosa parks said we can't stop them
we got to have federal law
and they went their way then some young
students
the young former that day they became
freedom writers and others did other
things and it took nine years
and they got the civil rights act
federally
they made it against federal law
congresswoman omar
to discriminate
when we've gone from all of these abuses
from oscar grant and aminu diallo and
others
all the way to philando castille right
here
in minneapolis area
we struggled through all of that but we
are going to now in his name in the name
of dante we're going to pass the george
floyd
justice in policing act as federal law
now you could tell that he wrote that in
about 12 minutes um in about 12 minutes
probably about 12 minutes before the
funeral
you can also tell that he's a soulless
phony
the air freshener reference comes from
the claim that dante wright was pulled
over and arrested because he had air
fresheners in his car actually you know
as we talked about last week the
original claim was that he was
shot for having air fresheners
and that's something that
that's something that thousands of
people believed and repeated they didn't
see any problem with that at all
they that didn't make them stop and go
wait what hold on a second
but like nearly every claim made by
activists after nearly every
high-profile police shooting it was
completely bogus right was pulled over
for a traffic violation and then
arrested because he had a warrant
stemming from a violent crime that he'd
committed a few months prior but that's
just the truth
and what's a little thing like truth to
a guy like sharpton
or a woman like ilhan omar who got on
stage to offer her own tribute to saint
dante and a sharpton himself and here's
what that sounded like if you can
stomach it
salaam alaikum everyone
thank you uh reverend ultra and for
being here
uh and for that beautiful
eulogy
most of us in this room including myself
look at you as a guardian
and are blessed to be in your presence
and may dante wright serve as a guardian
for all of us
but as a member of the congressional
black caucus
as one of the youngest and newest
members of the congressional black
caucus
i also
have guardians
congresswoman sheila jackson lee
and our chairwoman
joyce beatty
serve as guardians for me and many of my
colleagues
joyce beatty was going to be here and
speak on our behalf as the chairwoman of
our caucus
but just like we've been visited by
tragedy here in minnesota often
she
in columbus ohio
was visited by a tragedy
of a young woman whose life was taken by
columbus police
okay
first of all she really needs to choose
better guardians
al sharpton sheila jackson lee
those are your guardians
that's like if if you're at the beach
and the lifeguards are like piranhas or
something
but dante wright will be a guardian for
all of us so i stand corrected he's no
mere saint
he is an angel
he's a guardian angel
ilhan omar has given him a promotion
already
well far be it for me to pick and choose
but uh i i
would like to request a different
guardian if i could i'd really prefer a
guardian who's less likely to rob me at
gunpoint
guardians in fact are
supposed to protect you from guys like
dante right they're not supposed to be
guys like dante right unless this is a
keep your enemies close kind of
guardianship strategy i don't know
now i can tell you one woman who
certainly would not want right assigned
to her as a guardian angel
that would be the woman who called the
police one morning not long ago to
report that wright had pointed a gun at
her choked her and stuffed his hand down
her bra to steal her rent money
that's the crime he was charged with in
2019 when according to the victim he
came to her house for a party stayed the
night the next morning after her
roommate gave her money for rent he
pulled a gun out put his hand around her
throat and demanded all the cash
she started screaming eventually he left
without any money he was arrested
released on bail violated the terms of
his bail by possessing a firearm without
a permit then failed to show up for his
court appearance and finally was
apprehended during the traffic stop when
he resisted arrest and attempted to flee
with a woman in the car
this is our guardian angel
says ilhan omar
this is the man who was given a
statewide moment of silence
this is the man who with the nationally
televised funeral
a man who if he contributed anything at
all to his community seems to have
contributed mostly crime violence and
misery
perhaps he had some good qualities too
but on balance
it would seem that this was let's say
not a very good person
after all choking and robbing a woman at
gunpoint is not a minor mistake it's not
a youthful indiscretion
it reveals a total lack of empathy an
utter absence of concern or compassion
for your fellow man
does all that necessarily mean
that um you don't deserve the massive
nationally televised funeral attended by
famous politicians and accompanied by a
statewide moment of silence
well yeah it does mean that
this is not a small matter
you can discover everything you need to
know about a culture based on who it
chooses to honor
cultures that honor great men
not perfect men but great men
who achieved great things
live their lives with dignity and
courage
help to change the world in positive
ways
those cultures are vibrant and healthy
that's the kind of culture you want to
live in
but a culture that honors men who
achieved nothing of significance men of
no dignity and no honor men who are
known only because of the way they died
men whose last act on earth was to
resist arrest thereby refusing to accept
the just and fair consequences of their
own evil deeds
those cultures are decaying husks
and we are very much in the latter
category
one other thing to think about here
um
another effect of eulogizing right in
this way is that you wind up
dehumanizing him
you know the over the top honoring of
wright or floyd
or whoever else
means that
they're not really honored at all
you can't honor a man's life by
pretending that it was something other
than what it was
whoever was eulogized at the funeral of
dante right it certainly wasn't dante
wright
was a caricature a mascot a logo a prop
the democrat party the left blm they
came in took wright's name and turned
him into whatever they needed him to be
ironically by turning right into a saint
and an angel you erase him
he is replaced
by the poster boy that activists and
scummy politicians like ilhan omar
invent for their own purpose
and those purposes as we have seen
are quite sinister
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
now a quick word from x chair which is
the chair that i'm currently sitting in
and uh it's that you know that's an easy
decision to make to sit in this chair
every day um because x chair has you
covered for your office chair needs uh
whether you need it at the office or at
home or you have two x chairs because
listen you spend a lot of time probably
sitting down especially depending what
you do for a living
and that's why it's important to think
about what kind of chair you have just
like you spend a lot of time sleeping
and so we're all work you know we all
know the importance of having a good
mattress well the same thing same thing
goes for chairs the secret is not only
their patented dynamic variable lumbar
support which offers unbelievable lumbar
support to your lower back but now
thanks to their new ax hmt technology
you can get also get the the heat and
massage
in the chair you get that all that
therapy and that's built in to the chair
so you can have that while you're
sitting at the desk instead of your old
uncomfortable office chair now you can
look forward to spending hours sitting
in the ultimate
therapeutic massager the xhmt delivers
heat and massage technology right to
your core helping increase blood flow
muscle recovery and energy all the perks
that make working from home or the
office the joy xchair is on sale now for
a hundred dollars off go to
xchairwalsh.com now that's the letter x
chairwalsh.com or call one eight four
four four x chair x chair has a 30 day
guarantee of complete comfort and you
can finance your purchase for as little
as 30 bucks a month go to
xchairwalsh.com now and use code x
wheels for free x-wheel blade casters
xchairwalsh.com
all right good to be back in back in
nashville i was in uh austin last night
speaking at ut austin
um and uh i thought that wouldn't went
went very well
um and happy poke poked up friday by the
way
but
i i will say on the the plan i made the
mistake
on the plane ride home
of coughing
just one time and it was only because i
was drinking something and it went down
the wrong pipe you know and so i coughed
maybe it was like two coughs in
succession kind of healthy coughs you
know and and that's it
and of course everyone
looks at me
like they try to be subtle about it but
it's like you you just feel the stares
even if it's peripheral it's sort of
this record scratch moment from the
movies the music stops everyone looks
i would like to
live in a world again this is my dream
this is my utopian dream i want to live
in a world again
where you can cough or sneeze in public
and people won't look at you like you're
the guy in the zombie movie who comes
home with a bite mark on his arm
that's the world i want to live in
where you don't feel the need to explain
like any time you cough you have to
explain to people i don't know this is
it's just i was just drinking something
that's all it was
you're safe
um but uh you know i don't know i don't
know if we'll ever
live in that world again
um
especially when you've got people
like in like in austin you know i
i walked when i was in austin i walked
uh
maybe two blocks to go to the the
pharmacy down the street
and most of the people i saw wearing
masks you know outside which is not a
surprise for austin
but wearing masks cause i i you know i i
got in trouble because i tweeted
yesterday that uh i think
no i'm not recommending this i'm only
saying that i think it would be
acceptable
if you were to respond to someone
wearing a mask outside
by pointing and laughing at them
you know gawk point laugh i think that
would be an acceptable response
because wearing a mask outside is
psychotic behavior it really is
it's not scientifically justified at all
that is um behavior that should be
ostracized stigmatized which we'll talk
more about stigmas in the daily
cancellation
um all right
so we'll start with this a new angle on
the micaiah bryant shooting in columbus
ohio
this is from i believe a security camera
footage from a neighbor
and now look
the
the original footage that we saw
mikaya bryant again you know we know
this case 16 year old columbus ohio she
she was um
police were called because someone was
with had a knife and was trying to stab
people and then they show up and make
brian has a large knife and what do you
know is trying to stab people
so the body cam footage is enough right
there to vindicate the officer
not only get him off the hook on any
criminal charges but actually to reveal
him to be a hero he acted heroically
in that moment to save somebody's life
from a person was trying to stab them to
death
so we already have enough but i think
this other angle from security camera
footage
it's revealing because of what you can
hear micaiah bryan say well play this
um
it's gonna be a little difficult we have
to bleep it out so you're not really
gonna be able to hear it but uh it's
worth anyway to play so let's let's play
that
[Applause]
[Applause]
um
yeah really hard to hear especially
there with the bleeps
but she says
still clear enough she says i'm going to
stab the f out of you
b word that's what she says
and uh so she she announces
her intention to commit
uh you know to to uh
commit attempted murder basically
and then carries out
what she just threatened
it could not be more clear
she actually says i'm gonna stab you
with a knife and then tries to stab not
not one person two people
she goes for one woman who's not to the
ground
and then a guy comes in behind her and
and tries to stomp on that woman's face
and then she goes for the second woman
pins her against the car has the knife
out and is about to plunge it into that
into that person
um when the cop when the cop fired
this again is
it it sells it short to say that this
was uh a justified
shooting
i think
in a in a healthy insane world we'd be
pinning a medal on that cop
for his heroism
all right we'll have a little bit more
about the shooting later on in five
headlines um
next i want to play this here's a good
video
this is a mom in georgia her name is
courtney ann taylor at a gwinnett county
board of education meeting
and she's
they're sending kids to school in
georgia
full school days um you know
in in gwinnett county
but the kids have to wear masks the
entire day
so you're talking
six or seven hours a day that these kids
are in masks
well courtney ann taylor's had enough of
it
and if you want to know what truth to
power sounds like it sounds like this
let's watch
every month i come here and i hear the
same thing
social emotional health
if you truly mean that you would end the
mask requirement tonight
tonight
this is not march 2020 anymore we have
three vaccines every adult in the state
of georgia that wants that vaccine is
eligible to get it right now and every
one of us knows that young children are
not affected by this virus
they're not and that's a blessing but as
the adults what have we done with that
blessing
we've shoved it to the side and we've
said we don't care you're still going to
wear a mask on your face every day five
and six-year-olds you still can't play
together on the playground like normal
children seven and eight-year-olds we
don't care we're still going to force
you to carry a burden that was never
yours to carry shame on us
and i know what i'm going to be met with
but miss taylor the cdc we did not vote
for people at the cdc
we did elect leaders who do create
policy we elected the five of you we
chose you to make difficult decisions
for our children we chose you to make
decisions that would be in our
children's best interests and forcing
five six seven eight and nine-year-old
little children to cover their noses and
their mouths where they breathe for
seven hours a day every day for the last
nine months for a virus that you know
doesn't affect them
that is not in their best interest
it has to stop take these off of our
children
[Applause]
amazing i mean that really i love that
video
it's hard to say i love it given this
what the circumstances and how
justifiably upset and outraged
that mother is but
that is as i said that's true truth to
power you know it's that's standing up
and she's exactly right
a couple things she said there really
resonate
um one is
my six-year-old can't come up here and
say this
you know and they can't the kids can't
advocate for themselves the teachers
they advocate for themselves they have a
teacher's union
only cares about the interests of the
teacher it doesn't care at all about
about
about the students
so they can get what they want
um yeah all all the adults can have
their special interest groups and all
these kinds of things and we can and we
can
complain publicly we can go online we
can all do all this
we can go to these meetings
but the kids can't
so what they need
um are adults
who are willing to advocate for them
and that's
unfortunately that's a that's a problem
you know that's like too much to ask
in our society today to have adults that
will advocate for children
because a lot of adults in this country
don't really care about kids
when we kill a million of them a year in
the womb so what does that tell you
do we don't recognize them as people
so legally we don't recognize them as
people but at least when they're in the
womb
they're in the early stages of life so
and that's what this
that's why i've been talking about it
myself
what she says there this is not their
burden to carry they're not right there
that's it
not their burden to carry
whatever else you want to say about all
the other
coveted measures as they pertain to
adults
that should have been our stance from
day one
you know the fact that and we we knew
this almost immediately this is one of
the facts
about kovid that we knew from the
beginning and has remained true there
are a lot of facts that we thought were
facts and turn out not to be
there are other things we didn't know
that we found out later but but one
thing we always knew
almost from the beginning is that this
doesn't really affect kids
they're not at a high risk to be
infected by it
they're not at a at a high risk to
spread it doesn't mean it's impossible
but if they're not a high risk category
they're low risk
and that is such an
incredible blessing because it doesn't
have to be that way a virus can do
whatever a virus is going to do this you
know this could have gone the opposite
this could have been a virus that
especially affected kids imagine that
imagine if it was 500 000 dead children
from this
that's not the way it was and so that's
a that's a wonderful thing so what we
could have said is look as adults and as
we get especially older adults we got to
be more careful these are these are
burdens we have to carry things we're
going to have to do
but the kids can continue living their
lives
and the other thing we should have said
as adults is that
yeah you know what if the kids continue
living their lives and they go to school
and they go to the playground they don't
have to wear a mask
um
there's a little bit of an elevated risk
that they'll carry the virus home to an
adult and one of us will get sick
but you know what we should have said so
be it that's okay i'm willing to take
that risk for the sake of the kids
i would rather
not only risk getting coveted i would
rather get covid
i'd rather willingly get it and be
infected by it
if it means that my child can live a
normal life
if it's a choice between
taking my child's childhood away for a
year and counting
you know doing that or protecting myself
from the virus
no i'll i'll take the virus in that in
that trade
that should have been the attitude it
should have been everyone's attitude but
it wasn't and that's it is a it is a
disgrace and a shame that i think we'll
have to um
i think
our generation of adults we're going to
carry this with us into the history
books
you know when when people look back on
this on this absurdity
of putting kids in masks putting caution
tape around playgrounds
shutting down the schools for a virus
that doesn't even really affect these
kids
kicking them off of planes kicking
two-year-olds off of planes for not
wearing masks
people in the future are gonna look back
on that and say what a bunch of cowardly
disgusting ridiculous
so-and-so's and they'll be right
in many cases not in the case of that
woman
and a few others
all right
next thing we've got lebron james is
facing mounting backlash as they say for
doxxing the hero cop who uh stopped
mikaya bryant from stabbing someone to
death
and it's gotten so bad
it's so bad for lebron james
that even o.j simpson
now
is giving lebron james ethical lectures
even
o.j simpson
is a voice of reason here for lebron
here's what oj had to say about all this
hey twitter world is me yours truly
tough morning listening to all the
criticism that lebron
james is getting uh
i'm a fan of lebron i admire the work
that he's done how he's helped his
community and how he's helped his
friends uh and he's been fighting all of
these social issues especially that of
systemic racism and the legal system and
with the police departments around our
country but you can't fight every battle
you know you can't uh you got to pick
your battles i mean it's a war that must
be fought but sometimes you need to take
your time and be a little more patient
before you comment on some of these um
uh bad incidences that are happening
with police departments uh this one
uh lebron should have waited uh i'm a
little upset with most of the
media because they showed us edited
versions of what took place with the
girl with the knife they made it sound
as if this was another police officer
overreacting and killing a young black
american well for what i saw when i saw
the whole thing the police um guy had no
choice he responded
it's true the police guy didn't have a
choice and you know i mean in fairness
o.j simpson is uh you know an expert
in um killing people with knives so
he's kind of kind of a stabbing expert
maybe he could maybe be
maybe cable news channel can bring him
on as the the stabbing consultant for
any any stabbing related news
and even this guy
uh is is has a better take on this than
lebron james
what does that tell you
of course as of right now
lebron's corporate backers haven't said
anything the nba hasn't said anything
about this his sponsors nike et cetera
et cetera none of them have addressed
this at all
when when you've got the
most high-profile athlete in the world
putting the face of a police officer up
there and saying you're next
and his only crime
stopping a black woman from being
stabbed to death
all right let's see
this is from meteorite reports that the
u.s senate just passed the covet 19 hate
crimes bill in a bipartisan vote of 94
to 1.
the one outlier in the vote to pass a
bill designed to limit the sharp
increase in hate crime towards
asian and pacific island americans was
missouri senator josh hawley whose vote
against an anti-asian or anti-hate
crimes bill
may one day be viewed as the most
hallean act ever i don't know why i'm
reading the media report on this one
anyway um they've got what i really
wanted to get to was the specifics of
what this bill is supposed to do okay
josh holly was the one guy voted against
it and he did explain it and he said
that um
this was his statement from the office
of senator hawley he said it's too broad
as a former prosecutor my view is it's
dangerous to simply give the federal
government open-ended authority to
define a whole new class of federal hate
crime incidents
that's a it's a really reasonable point
of view um it's the troubling thing for
me is not that
i am troubled that he was the only guy
to say that but it's because he's the
only one
every other republican should have
joined him
in that view so cnn reports on what this
bill would do um
the bill would direct the departments of
justice and health and human services to
issue guidance
raising awareness of hate crimes during
the pandemic and to work with agencies
to establish online reporting of them
so it's
it directs departments to issue guidance
to raise awareness
senator majority leader chuck schumer
said thursday the bill is proof that the
senate can work to solve important
issues and would tell bigots we're going
after you
what issue have you solved
it's not proof of anything
no it's proof that you can
exploit tragedies for political gain
that's what it proves we already knew
that chuck
not a surprise to me
what what have you solved
in what way does any of this
prevent a single hate crime against an
asian person can you explain that
we've solved it now hey don't worry you
know
asian woman is stomped
outside of a hotel
a couple weeks ago
and so chuck schumer is saying hey don't
worry
we've issued guidance
to raise awareness
you're welcome
accomplishes nothing whatsoever
it is a one big virtue signal from
everybody in the senate all republicans
included
wish i could say i was surprised by that
but i'm not
josh hawley's the only guy saying come
on this is
you guys know what you're doing this is
pointless
we
it is already illegal
to commit hate crimes against asian
people
as it should be
it's already illegal on multiple levels
if you assault an asian person
because they're asian
it's illegal because it's assault
it's illegal because it's a hate crime
so it's illegal on two levels
and and you're you've got federal and um
and local authorities coming after you
for that
why do we need another bill on top of
that
what reinforcing the fact that it's
illegal now it goes from illegal to
super illegal
no it's not gonna do anything it doesn't
accomplish anything but again it's um
it's it is just the
the naked exploitation of tragedy by
by the senate and that's how you know
see chuck schumer says well see everyone
agrees that's how you know this is a
good no it's when everyone agrees that's
how you know it's a really bad bill
if they can all agree
all right i want to play this for you uh
going back to the mackay bryant shooting
so there have been of course a lot of
really really bad takes on this and um
[Music]
both juan williams and fox news and joy
reid
we'll go to joy read first
uh they had they had similar
takes on
what the cop should have done instead
because when you watch the video and and
you see how fast this all unfolded and
this woman was this this girl was
wielding a knife
and you could say all you want it's very
sad that the girl ended up dead it is
sad it's always sad when someone dies
but if you're going to blame the cop you
better be able to explain what he could
have done differently
and some some people in media have tried
they've given it a shot to explain what
he could have done differently and so
give him credit for trying
but i i think their answers leave
something to be desired so here's joy
reid on what the cops should have done
instead of shooting mikaya bryant
i mean it seems to me in a situation
this is what it looked like to me and
i've looked at the tape and i still
can't figure it out
um
shoot the gun in the air there's a
warning tase a person shoot them in the
leg shoot them in the behind
you know stop them somehow but if the
only solution
is to kill the a teenager there's
something wrong with this there's
something very very wrong
um
okay that's by the way that's joy behar
i knew it was someone named joy with a
room temperature iq
um
getting confused sometimes so
yeah she says uh yeah i don't know just
uh shoot the gun in the air
that'll stop
you know just randomly shoot the gun in
a different direction
away from the person trying to stab
someone
juan williams had basically the same
take let's listen to what he has to say
what does juan williams officer juan
williams do to save the ladies life in
pink
well i guess i would shoot the gun not
necessarily at somebody but maybe shoot
the gun and maybe you know run at the
person and try to disarm them like i
don't know i mean so wait wait wait you
would shoot the gun in the air like a
warning shot
not well hopefully to distract or to try
to stall or something so i could get or
my partner could get the knife away i
see is what i was saying i don't know i
mean taking someone's wife is pretty
strong
i don't either i don't either jesse i
mean jesse policing is tough work
um but all i'm saying is you know i
think
i think that that woman with a knife is
a danger to society it's certainly a
danger to the other person and we want
her to stop and be disarmed i just i
just also think that killing a human is
pretty radical i don't think that's a
good thing but what i see overall here
you know you asked me what i see i see
people now using this ohio case which is
messy as you and i just discussed
to somehow really try to change the
subject you know from what happened in
minnesota with the
chauvin uh guilty verdict
okay juan so just shut up then you you
don't know i i don't know what he should
do just not something different i don't
know
he should make it so that the thing
that's happening isn't happening anymore
what's and he should do without killing
anyone why is that so hard
okay well give us a specific plan and
tell us how it works well i don't have a
plan i don't know
not that something other than that
oh great analysis
let's see why you need juan williams on
to deliver that kind of analysis
killing someone is pretty radical pretty
extreme oh really one yeah i didn't
realize
that no well thanks for thanks for
clearing that up
i thought cops were supposed to just go
out and just kill everybody
doesn't matter you know just walk down
the street randomly kill people they
could be criminals you know that's what
i thought they were supposed to do but
now you're explaining that it's a it's a
it's an extreme step
yeah it is an extreme step you're in an
extreme situation
where a woman a girl is trying to stab
someone to death right in front of you
that's an extreme it's a radical
situation i i would say
trying to stab someone to death in front
of a police officer
that's a radical step
and that's going to be met with a
radical response
shoot a warning shot
this
like we i talked about yesterday i tried
to explain in detail this is not we
don't live in the movies
cops don't do that you don't
no one should do that
a lot of reasons number one
what goes up must come down it's called
gravity
so you shoot the gun in some other
direction it's it it
you don't know what it's gonna end up
hitting
i can tell you this when you shoot it
off in the air the gun the bullet
doesn't evaporate just because you can't
see it anymore
doesn't mean it's evaporated it's still
out there somewhere and it might hit
something
um also why
she's got the
the woman pinned she has the the kitchen
knife
she's she's you know she's
uh winding up
all she has to do is bring her arm
forward
you shoot a gun in another direction why
would that stop her
distract her
that's your goal that's what you think
you're gonna do distract them
okay well how about you know how about
this let's have cops um
every cop forget about social workers
every cop should have with them on their
team
a clown
and so anytime there's a violent crime
in process you have the clown run out
and start and start doing hijinks
and the hijinks will distract the
criminal and they'll look over and say
what's that what's that clown over there
and then they'll get tackled and uh and
you know with this plan
nobody will ever be killed by the cops
again
worst case scenario you give the clown a
gun too and you know at least then the
clown is doing the killing
i mean all you can do is joke about it
because this is this is so
words escape me
to describe this kind of thing
and the real answer here is that you
know these people
they know
they know that if they were in that
situation they'd probably do the exact
same damn thing
but that's not gonna stop them from from
throwing this police officer under the
bus
all right let's uh
move on to reading the comments i had
okay i had one other thing i wanted to
play
i got to play this just because it was
it was earth day yesterday in fact i
feel bad that was earth day yesterday
and i never acknowledged it um i never
i i didn't it wasn't i didn't realize so
i apologize ahead of time i apologize to
mother earth to gaia for forgetting her
birthday but it was earth day and the
only thing i want to play i got a few
clips i could play all of them but there
were these climate change activists the
environmental activists extinction
rebellion
and they were out um
you know they were this was in the uk
and the united states they were in dc in
dc they they had wheelbarrows full of
cow manure
and they marched up in front of i think
was the white house and they dumped all
their cow manure
so they're
polluting in an effort to save that
here's here's the
eclipse here okay so that's cow manure
they're dumping their cow manure
so polluting and littering in the name
of helping the environment
real heroes here and you know what's
gonna happen
some
low-wage sanitation worker
could be a racial minority is gonna have
to come in and clean all that crap up
literally queen not clean that crap up
so well done so these privileged white
people come in and dump
cow manure all over the place
meaning that a low-wage worker's got to
come and clean it
and then oh yeah this is what i wanted
to play so let's play this here's here
they are i think this was somewhere it
might have been in london
and extinction rebellion they're
smashing windows
but they're doing it in the most
pathetic and girliest way i've ever seen
like they ca they've got sledgehammers
but they don't have the strength they're
on the strength to simply smash the
window with the sledgehammer
so they're doing in this in this very
surgical kind of slow way
[Music]
and they never they never successfully
smashed it
they couldn't they couldn't even smash
the window
man
these environmental activists are not
sending their best
look if you're gonna do that send
someone with some upper body strength
but of course what am i talking about
it's their environmental activists they
don't have it in with upper body
strength
even the guys could even do one pull-up
it's it's a shame it really is
but um so they did damage the glass and
so that means that
we have to make more glass and put it in
and that's going to help the environment
in some way that escapes me
now i want to thank our sponsors mac
weldon um listen you guys know that i
know something about fashion hence the
polka dot shirt actually don't this
polkadot shirt is not mac welding don't
blame them for that and you might say i
don't know a lot about fashion which is
why i need help and that's uh and that's
one of the that's where mac weldon comes
in for me anyway you should always bring
the comfort and style of mac welding
along with you whether it's their
hoodies polos tees or active shorts
everything in the mac welding collection
mixes and matches seamlessly to fit in
with any other product you have sock
shirts hoodies underwear polos active
shorts mac welding promises comfort and
a consistent fit
for working out going out going to work
or on a date whatever you're doing mac
weldon has something for you it's all
about everyday life they've got
something for whatever whatever you're
doing with your time there's a a mac
welding product that will fit perfectly
in more ways than one um and the weld in
blue uh something you should look into
it's a totally free loyalty program
level one gets you free shipping for
life once you reach level two by
spending 200 bucks you get 20 off every
order for the next year mack weldon
wants you to be comfortable
so if you don't like your first pair of
underwear you can keep them and they'll
still refund you no questions asked
you'll have to return the underwear okay
don't do that that's gross for 20 off
your first order visit macweldon.com
walsh and enter promo code walsh that's
macweldon.com promo code walls for 20
off mack weldon reinventing men's basics
okay let's let's move into reading the
youtube comments
this is from um
a.s says odd how speaking of mikaya
bryan odd how her mom didn't even look
that upset while talking about her
daughter who just died
yeah you know listen i
i think
i can remember back to sandy hook
when the terrible shooting you know
uh
many children were were shot in a mass
shooting at a school and
after that
there were some of the parents were you
know
it might have been that day but in the
days after some parents were talking to
the media
and i remember them being criticized
because they didn't look sad enough
about it
and that criticism really annoyed me
because you know
first of all you can't judge
someone's grief based on their facial
expression
people process things differently
um they communicate it differently
and when you're going through something
so devastating as to lose a child
there's there's just no way to if you've
never been through it yourself you
really can't
make any judgments about
parents who and how they process it that
being said
um
the
going out in front of cameras
within moments
right
and
really lying
about
your loved one
that i don't think can be justified and
that is hard for me to understand
it's hard for me to understand how that
would be part of the grieving process
now listen
if i had a
a kid
who got themselves shot by the cops
because they were in the process of
trying to stab someone to death uh i
would i'm not going to go out in front
of the cameras and throw my kid under
the bus and say he was a terrible person
as a parent i'm not going to say that
but i think i can say that what i would
do is i wouldn't say anything i just i
wouldn't be in front of the cameras and
if i did end up in front of a camera i
wouldn't claim that my child was an
angel
so it's not so much the the look on the
face or anything but it's like in these
situations it's what the families
sometimes say
and so often in these police shootings
the family comes out first and they have
a narrative and it turns out to be
totally completely wrong
all right um
another comment says responsible parents
would have given her the talk about how
you only stab people when the police
aren't standing right there well
yeah it's it
you know we heard that mikaya bryan uh i
don't know i don't know who called the
cops and
another part of the the initial
narrative was that she had called the
cops
that seems unlikely to me because
whoever called said that oh this person
has a knife and she was the one with a
knife
but if she did that makes it like even
worse that you call the cops and then
they show up and they're here now and
then you start trying to stab someone
um hannah says i've decided to go on a
media fast starting saturday i will miss
you most matt
well then you know what
you can't quit you're fired
you're banned from the show
media look you can go on a fast from all
over the media i think it's a great
thing to do but don't don't let me in
i'm not like them
uh but no seriously that's probably a
good thing for your psychological health
no one else is allowed to do it okay
you're the exception but probably you
know it's probably a good idea clint
williams says hey matt how did you cut
your finger whittling an arrow out of a
tree branch well um yeah i did mention
that in passing yesterday so i was i was
uh you know i was watching my kids and
um
uh yeah i mean i was i was
of course i'm watching my kids i'm i'm
the father but uh my wife wasn't there
is the point and uh and if she was she
probably would have put a stop to this
because i was with my kids and and they
were saying oh daddy can you make arrows
out of tree branches and um i've never
done that before
so i said sure you know let me go grab a
knife and i gave it a shot and i was
kind of whittling and the the knife came
right down to my finger huge gaping hole
i was bleeding all over the place
and as i'm
blood's gushing out
and i'm trying like i'm trying to
contain the blood i want to get it on
the floor
and i'm looking around and i'm texting
my wife trying to be subtle about it
saying like hey hey was where are the
band-aids by a chance
and she told me i said what about gauze
what about disinfectant don't worry i
just i'm just wondering i'm trying to do
an inventory but anyway as i'm looking
around for everything to bandage my uh
my finger that i almost cut off
that's when my son starts asking me if
he can have a snack
so
you can tell how concerned he was
it was a smart move though because of
course i said yeah take whatever snack
you want okay i'm trying not to
bleed to death here
yeah there's a few things worse in your
daily life than uh getting a bout of
nausea uh and maybe let's say you're
hungover
some of you heathens out there may have
experienced that in your life
uh or getting cars sick i was just you
know when traveling i was just in a car
and i didn't have my relief been on me i
forgot it at home and so i suffered in
dignified silence
like a man but i wish i had it uh that's
why you need relief ben it's the number
one fda cleared anti-nausea wristband
that's been clinically proven to quickly
relieve and effectively prevent nausea
and vomiting associated with motion
sickness anxiety migraine hangover
morning sickness chemotherapy and so
much more the product is 100 drug-free
it's non-drowsy
um which puts it you know far and away
above a lot of the other anti-nausea
medication out the medications out there
and this is not a medication at all this
is drug free provides all natural relief
with zero side effects for as long as
you need the technology was originally
developed over 20 years ago in hospitals
to relieve nausea from patients but now
through relief band it's available to
the masses and you've got to try this
yourself
this new year ensure that nausea is
never the reason to miss out on life's
big moments right now relief ban has an
exclusive offer just for matt walsh
listeners if you go to reliefband.com
and use promo code walsh you'll receive
20 off plus free shipping and no
questions asked 30 day money back
guarantee so head to r e l i e f b
d
and use promo code walsh for 20 off
well you know it's um
time to jump in the ring and catch the
latest episode of candace tonight at 9pm
eastern 8pm central only on
dailywire.com
uh candace is fired up about the events
of the week she's got a lot to say as
always but to get the full uncensored
version of awards you have to become a
daily wire member so join in um join in
time to catch tonight's live stream and
get 25 off a new membership with code
candice at dailywire.com subscribe
that's not all candace is joined by
another ultimate fighter guest dana
white the president of the ufc
subscribe now and stream candace tonight
at 8 p.m eastern uh rather i should say
9 p.m eastern 8 p.m central i'm still
figuring out the time zone thing only on
daily wire and get 25 off a new
membership with code candace again
that's dailywire.com subscribe now let's
get to our daily cancellation
today for our daily cancellation we turn
again sad to say to slate the article
tweeted out by the website yesterday has
this headline
how gen z is using p
to destigmatize sex online
now i'm not going to subject you to
many of the details all i will say is
that according to slate there's a
subculture on tick-tock wherein people
with urine fetishes post videos
celebrating that fetish that's what they
say
slate is happy that this is
destigmatizing freaks who get sexual
pleasure out of other people's human
waste
and more broadly they say it's
destigmatizing discussions and
depictions of sex online
now don't worry i'm not going to play
any of the p videos that would require
me to search for them and watch them
myself and there are some tick tock
bridges too far for even me to cross
besides i think we all get the idea
right we probably don't need to see it
what i want to talk about though is not
urine ophelia or whatever we're supposed
to call it
instead i want to discuss more broadly
the concept of stigma
you'll notice that the left is
constantly fighting to end
the stigmas around various proclivities
fetishes perversions and so forth
they look out and see a world where too
many things are stigmatized
now i look out and see precisely the
opposite
because stigmas in fact are good things
and we should have more of them
in fact we should add another we should
stigmatize destigmatization
now the first problem with the left's
rush to destigmatize is that many of the
stigmas they seek to destroy don't
actually exist anymore and have them for
quite some time i mean
destigmatize sex online are you are you
serious
that may have been at least a
comprehensible objective in 1994 when
people were logging on to aol 1.0 on
their dial-up modems but in 2021
sex is the primary focus of the internet
it seems rather impossible to make sex
on the internet less stigmatized than it
is
it's like trying to destigmatize i don't
know big macs at mcdonald's
sex on the internet is not stigmatized
but it should be
not because sex is bad
the point isn't that sex itself should
be stigmatized
but sex as public spectacle should be
sex where both partners or all 10
partners or however many
are commodities products
to be used by each other and the viewer
sex without love without dignity
that's what should be stigmatized
see they're basically as far as i can
tell two categories of stigma
that the left seeks to tear down or to
keep torn down
one is where they want an objectively
bad thing to be accepted and celebrated
this is where they try to tear down the
stigmas around you know open
relationships for example which is
another way of saying they want to
destigmatize adultery or they want to
get rid of the stigma of abortion hoping
to build a utopian society where women
can have their child children executed
without judgment or shame again it's
arguable whether there really is any
stigma surrounding those things anymore
but but there should be
another version of this destigmatizing
campaign is
when a thing that is not a moral evil
but is a private matter
is pushed into the public square
sex again sex big example here
um every personal thing really is an
example these days people tend to share
every aspect of themselves with the
whole world putting the good the bad and
the ugly on display
little remains private
in fact there's almost no such thing as
a private life anymore for a lot of
people there's no this is what the
internet has done
there's no private life there's no
interior
mental life
everything you do is broadcast on the
internet everything you think is is
filtered through the internet
everything is shared
and if you ever suggest that someone
should keep some of the more intimate
details of themselves to themselves
you'll be accused of
stigmatizing the the destigmatizing
efforts around mental illness are also
kind of interesting
you know mental illness is bad
in the sense that it's something a
person suffers from but it's not a moral
evil
obviously a personal mental illness
can't be blamed for it in one sense it
seems a worthy goal to break down the
stigma surrounding you know that sort of
affliction but
the drive to destigmatize becomes always
and inevitably
a push to celebrate
and romanticize
and proliferate now we're told that 20
of the country is mentally ill and the
number is rising
which is absurd of course
um if mental illness is that common then
how can you even call it an illness
but it's become trendy and normalized
and this is the result
the overall goal the stated goal at
least is to break down all traditional
stigmas
so that we can live as free and
unencumbered human beings
you know the stigma around obesity is
another big example
um
big example no pun intended but now they
think about it is intended
once all the stigmas are gone and all of
our flaws foibles and afflictions are
celebrated and normalized we can be
happy and content you know living
without judgment or shame or insecurity
that's the promise anyway
and yet it hasn't worked out that way
you notice that as the stigmas all come
down
happiness and and contentment
have not really increased in fact people
have never been as depressed anxious and
lost as they are right now
the utopian promises of the left have
failed to pan out once again
because it turns out that healthy
societies have stigmas
in order to guide people towards a
healthy and properly ordered life
stigmas help people understand what's
good what's bad what's private what's
public
now there can be stigmas worth tearing
down sometimes but when you rip them all
down at once and invite everyone to
indulge themselves in whatever they the
way they see fit and wherever they see
fit
the somewhat ironic result is that
people end up paralyzed
take away all the fences and people can
go anywhere they want and they just
stand still don't know where to go
unsure of what to do where to go who to
be
you know you see a similar thing in
marriages with the deconstruction of
gender roles kind of a related
phenomenon it was supposed to be freeing
to let husband and wife choose their own
roles without any preconceived ideas or
stigmas at all
but this has led to confusion and to
failed marriages
if the husband has no idea about what
he's supposed to do or what role he's
supposed to fill and the same for the
wife
then they both end up feeling like they
do everything while accusing the other
of doing nothing
it's not a complimentary relationship
anymore but a competitive one
see roles responsibilities stigmas
these are all good things in principle
there could be bad versions of them
there are bad stigmas we can have ideas
about what what someone's role is and we
could be wrong about that so it's worth
looking at
but when you try to get rid of all those
things
in principle
as we've discovered you don't end up
with a
a bunch of happy and content people you
end up with quite the opposite and
that's why
stigmas are not canceled today but
destigmatizing that's what's cancelled
and uh we will leave it there for the
week
thanks a lot have a great weekend
godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens production
manager pavel vadosky the show is edited
by sasha tulmachov our audio is mixed by
mike coromina hair makeup is done by
nika geneva and our production
coordinator is mckenna waters the matt
wall show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin